hello everyone and welcome back to the
quarterfinals of the
uh opera euro rapids tournament it's
magnus carlson versus daniel dubois this
is game three of their match and as
you've seen magnus won the first game
and then game two ended in a draw but it
was a it was a
very interesting game uh but uh decided
to skip that one as i can show all the
games unfortunately even though that
that would be great uh but this is the
third one and it features a most
exciting opening uh here duba goes for
the scandinavian defense and
he goes for my favorite line the queen
to d61 so let's check out uh how he does
against magnus in this
as so far i think anyone who ever faced
magnus with this
opening lost terribly i know some i
don't know who he played
maybe kuzubova i think he faced him in
uh last year as a world blitz
championship with that queen to d6 idea
and also i know uh a nice blitz game
against alireza ferrugia where
i think maybe furuja no no or maybe
carlson played
that exact same line against firuja
either way it is on the channel so do
check it out
if you get a chance so here magnus with
the white pieces opens with
e4 we have d5 going for the scandinavian
defense e captures and e5
queen captures and denies the c3 so this
is the
main way to attack the scandinavian and
now queen to d6
this is the uh the the line that i
myself enjoy playing the most and it
offers a lot of a lot of cool
possibilities for black
if you haven't seen it i've made a
tutorial on how to play this uh with the
black piece so we'll put a link to it in
the description below first thing you'll
see
uh if you're interested in checking it
out so here the four by magnus and now
knight to f6 by do both with knight to
f3 and now
knight to c6 so not bothering by with
playing the a6 move
something i i covered in my uh tutorial
on how to play this but the dubo prefers
to play without it and he allows this
knight to b5 idea
so magnus immediately goes for it knight
to b5
attacks the queen and now queen back to
d8 the queen is very safe on d8
uh of course you have to guard the c7
pawn and now comes
bishop to e2 and interestingly already
as of move seven we have a completely
new game
here known moves are c4 and also d5 is a
known move
in this position d5 is a tricky move it
seems like uh you're giving your
opponent a pawn but like we said you
cannot uh
allow this because now you lose the
queen also something you you might want
to know if you're if you're playing
uh the scandinavian or against the
scandinavian
so here after bishop to e2 a new move
like we said
now a6 chasing away carlson's knight uh
knight to a3 and now the situation on
the clock is already very very
interesting magnus nine minutes whereas
dubo has all of his 15 minutes on the
clock so this is well within his
preparation
and magnus needs to figure out how to
ideally place his pieces so here
bishop to g4 uh just a normal normal
development band
of the bishop and now knight to c4 the
knight is not very useful under on the
edge of the board we have e6
and now castles by magnus we have bishop
to e7 dubai also ready to castle
and c3 now strengthening the center here
loop of castles his king to safety
and now magnus says okay nothing is
really happening here i'm not really
worried about anything let's just grab
more space on the queen side and
i don't want to see b5 on the board so
here
knight to d5 uh just improving the
position of this knight and even a5 by
magnus so a very strong pawn there
uh we have bishop to d6 now uh maybe
with ideas of
of maybe capturing here maybe you can
bring the queen over to the
uh to to the king side but with the
knight and c4
attacking that bishop you don't really
you don't really want to allow that so
here
rook to e1 and rook to e8 now
and bishop to g5 now putting pressure on
the queen here
f6 pushing the the bishop back and uh
always it's interesting whether this is
one of those games where you should
not uh play f6 or not but we'll see we
have bishop to h4
and now knight c to e7 uh dugo starts
shifting the knight over to the king
side he wants to attack the bishop here
so bishop back to g3 and now bishop
captures them g3
h captures and now knights to f5 so do
slowly creeping in with the pieces uh
closer and closer to carlson's king
but magnus says uh nope i know pretty
much all of these structures i'm just
gonna play queen b3 go after your pawn
and you do your thing so here duboff
says yeah that's uh that's a pretty good
move uh he defends it with rook to b8
and now
bishop to d3 putting some pressure on
the knight here also queen uh can
retreat the c2 to increase pressure here
so here bishop to h5 bishop captures an
f3 if you're wondering is also possible
but after g captures yes you've opened
up the king a little bit but then king
g2 and the rook can come to h1 and uh
all of a sudden black is under attack so
here
after bishop to d3 we have bishop to h5
by double and now
knight c to d2 shifting the knight back
to e4
and here you want to prepare uh some
pawn pushes here maybe with c4
so bishop back to f7 aligning the bishop
nicely here with the queen also adding
the defender to the e6 pawn
and now queen back to c2 with ideas of
capture so bishop to g6
and now knight to b3 and now this knight
is coming to
the c5 and it's uh it's a question
whether black
should or should not uh play this b6
idea
if you play it of course the white
captures and then you will constantly
have to worry about your a6 pawn
it will be attacked attacked uh plenty
of times
so here duba first tries queen to d6 but
now comes
knight to c5 right away going after
those pawns
and now uh it's a very paralyzing move
there's
not much black can do here so do without
even thinking twice
plays b6 he uh decides the decides to
give up this a6 pawn with the idea that
if knight captures he's gonna go rook to
a8
and now after captures and captures uh
he's gonna he's gonna have uh
a lot more activity even though at the
price of a pawn
but magnus decides against this he
decides to go for a captures on b6 right
away
c captures and now knight to e4 with an
attack on the queen also interestingly
you could just capture here
because the b pawn cannot capture but
then you have to
see what happens after knight to c7
attacks the rook but then you attack the
queen
and then you bring your rook to safety
but it's uh it works either way so after
c captures on b6
knights the e4 right away queen to c7
and only now magnus goes for the pawn
rook captures on a6
we rook beat the c8 now uh and
here comes queen to a4 and now dubo
really has to
decide uh what's he going to do he's
down upon and
well he doesn't have all that all that
many active plans here but he is a
little bit better on time magnus has
some five and a half minutes
whereas duval has seven minutes on the
clock and double now does what the
dubois does best he starts pushing the
pawn
uh to to open up carlson's king side so
h5
and now knight eat a d2 here bishop to
b5 was
very very strong but again carlson
doesn't want to waste too much time and
even risk getting into time trouble
against dubo but bishop to b5 i'm just
going to show it because it's super
interesting you attack the rook and if
the rook moves
otherwise you're just going to capture
it so rook eat the d8 now you go rook a7
attack the queen and after the queen
moves you have something like bishop
here attacks the rook and the e6 pawn
and white just uh completely bust open
the position
so here uh after h5 this is possible but
magnus doesn't want to spend too much
time calculating this
so knight e to d2 first and
now comes king to h7 by do both we have
c4 pushing back the knight and now dubo
instantly plays
b5 he says he wants to uh he wants
magnus to capture with the queen so he
can get rook to b18 but magnus plays
b captures uh c captures on b5
uh ruins his pawn structure a little bit
but he's very happy with his past b
pawn so here duboff says all right let's
uh just continue with what we're doing
on the king side
he continues pushing the pawn h4 and
magnus grabs it
g captures uh and by g captures now no
longer controls the f4 square so do both
immediately occupies it knights to f4
there's always time uh to go for for
some pawn grabs with knight captures on
h4
uh but interestingly uh instead of
knights to f4
you could go for this uh knight captures
because the the bishop here is hanging
but
uh i guess dubois didn't want to
exchange too many pieces then if bishop
captures knight captures
you don't have all that many attackers
anymore and this b pawn is marching
forward so instead after g captures on
f4 we have knights to f4
now attacking the bishop here and bishop
back to f1 this bishop is now an
excellent defender here helping out with
the defense of the g2 pawn
bishop to h5 and now comes rook to c6
attacking doom of squeen we have queen
to f7
and now queen back to c2 and now uh
the rook is being attacked twice by the
queen and by the rook also
you have to be very careful uh this
queen is aligned with the king so the
knight cannot move there also might be
some
some tricks of rook captures rook at
some point uh
if this knight moves so anything could
happen here so here double plays queen
to g6 he
threatens some ideas here knight stage
three can always be dangerous
you have to play something king h1 and
then maybe knight captures on f2
so uh king the h2 by magnus magnus uh
it would take too much time to calculate
rook capture sun c8
but again as uh so many of you enjoy
this i will show what happens because
it's uh
quite the madness here if magnus
accepted this rook captures on c8 then
we go into this line of knight to h3
check
h2 knight captures on f2 and now uh the
move you have to find otherwise you're
just allowing queen to g3 check
knight to g5 you have to give back a
little bit material
uh to block the queen's uh path to the
g3 square so f captures
now you pick up this rook and now g
captures on h4 again going for this
queen g3
now knight to e4 the knight now guards
the g3 square and now
knight captures uh and now not queen
captures but rook captures on e6
you could also play rook captures on e4
but uh
you know either works so rook captures
an e6 attacks the queen you allow this
check
king to g1 and now queen captures an e1
grabs the rook but after queen captures
on e4 now there are no more
uh checks or anything so white perfectly
uh
why defend it perfectly and after
captures captures is just a winning end
game for white
so i i showed it as i know you guys
enjoy it
but you know asking someone to you know
even
even start thinking about this in a
rapid game uh is
not happening so here king h2 a nice uh
safety move by magnus not allowing
quinta
uh quinta uh you know uh
and not currently go to g3 but you have
to be careful of this knight stage three
check like we said in the night captures
on f2 and so on so
king h2 stopping that and now rook c to
d a dubo of course has to save the rook
he cannot afford trading
uh more material queen to e for now
uh and now comes knight to d5
so the knight is under attack you have
to do something about it you could play
queen to g4
but the queen to g4 but then g3 and uh
where what are you doing the knight is
hanging queen captures knight is coming
so here knight to d5 by do both and now
magnus just
goes uh collecting material rook
captures on e6
he says there's nothing you can do here
on the king side so i'm not very worried
uh we have knight to c7 by double but
now magnus just trades as that's of
course his plan
so row captures rook captures attacking
the queen here
queen to b1 now and now rook captures
any one we have queen captures
and here knight to d5 by dubois but here
magnus just plays queen to e4
and he was in this position on 42 that
daniel duval resigned the game
as there is nothing more to be done so
the attack is over there's no way to
increase the pressure everything is
nicely defended and the magnus is just
up too much material he's just gonna
start pushing those pawns
uh and that's it not uh not even not
even close night after e7 for example or
night here
you can just start pushing the pawn or
if this knight remains here to defend
the b6 square for example you try
and go for a queen trait or something
then you can even go bishop d3
and i mean there's nothing for black to
look for here anymore
it's just a completely winning uh yeah
in the game for for white
so after queen to e4 uh dubo resigned
and
the first day match goes to magnus so
we'll see
uh what happens in the next one as he
won the first one in the third one and
there are four games of course that's
more than enough for a win as the second
game was drawn so double will get his
chance to bounce back but
it it's not going to be easy so
that's what you get when you try to
queen to d6 scandinavian against
magnus carlsen uh but like i said maybe
maybe you guys will enjoy
do check out the link in the description
below it
it has its moments uh so yeah uh that's
the game hope you guys enjoy it uh
enjoyed it we're gonna cover some other
games of course from the semi-finals uh
uh
probably tomorrow so stay tuned for that
i know you guys are very much looking
forward to the mvl 11 game so of course
we're going to cover that
uh i would like to thank mr pasta
services antonique uh preston lerner
janet hadway and bryce foster for a
contribution to my channel
thank you a lot i really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here
thank you for watching and i will see
you soon continuing the coverage of this
wonderful tournament
checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world
so thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day